lieutenant sir why are we here
it's zombies again fast ones are slow
ones sir
slow my god they're slow next stop
Pleasant Valley
Oh today we're having a super fun time
on our trip in the line in front of me
[Music]
must be something in the way
Oh be scared numbers how to play tag
what those funny-looking people up there
we're all gonna die I'll lick on the
dime is Caroline know this part of the
game the zombies are not real
is a bit scary what's the song we can
sing we can't stay here indefinitely I'm
not going anywhere
you're bigger idiots than I thought and
I thought you were both the stupidest
people I've ever met my job is to keep
you safe
stay here until I get back
that kind of behavior is unacceptable
let's start now that is five years old
and if you can't use appropriate
language with a five-year-old I'm going
to have to ask you to doesn't attract it
and wait for
[Music]
how do you like it oh god what have I
done
what's that oh I got caught in the
middle of a jam fight don't taste it
okay
you